most of the time when you're afraid of
something we don't actually call it fear
we call it something smarter we call it
a reason which is really just an excuse
which is really just fear but we call it
a reason I can't do that now because I
don't have enough time I didn't go to
school for that I don't have the
resources I don't have the experience
I'm going to start that next week or
this is a great January first goal and
you convince yourself of all the reasons
why you can't do it we come up with all
these stories these reasons and you
believe the reason because they're smart
reasons they're smart you wouldn't
believe a stupid reason it's a smart
reason that's what you're believing but
really just fear so step number one is
to actually catch the fear to stop
believing your excuses